now I'd like to introduce our speaker
for today
Melissa Valentine is an assistant
professor at Stanford University in the
management science and engineering
department and co-director of the Center
for work technology and organization her
award-winning research focuses on
designing groups and organizations how
the rise of information technology has
impacted organizational behavior and how
new technology can improve
organizational structures and outcomes
professor Valentine's work makes
contributions to understanding classic
and long-standing challenges in
designing groups and organizations deep
knowledge of how to rise of how the rise
of information technology has made the
possible new and different team and
organizational forms our most recent
study examined how the deployment of new
algorithms changed the organizational
structure of a retail tech company thank
you very much Melissa and I will turn it
over to you good morning everyone thank
you so much for joining I look forward
to interacting with you throughout the
webinar I wanted to start by putting
this research about how data and
platforms are changing team design in
historical context I want to talk about
sort of what technological trends this
research is a part of and how it's
important for society and for how work
is structured so what I'm showing here
is a graph from a book called the
vanishing American corporation by Jerry
Davis who's a professor at University of
Michigan so he motivates this book with
this story in 2009 a large retail chain
called Circuit City went out of business
shortly after that a company called
system X bought the Circuit City domain
name and ran the Circuit City website
I'm still continuing to fulfill customer
orders for electronic goods but running
this website running the Circuit City
domain name took fewer than 50 employees
in contrast to the 30,000 person work
force who had been running Circuit City
previously so that one story illustrates
some of the dynamics of this graph which
again comes from Jerry's book
he has rigorously studied the number of
corporations in the United States over
time and he's shown that the population
of public corporations are shrinking
there are more who are exiting than
entering this population at this time
those that come into business typically
employ a smaller workforce than the ones
that are going out of business so as
illustrated here in 2015 the combined
workforces of Facebook Yelp Zynga
LinkedIn Zillow tableau zuly and box or
smaller than the number of people who
lost their jobs when the circuitcity was
liquidated in 2009 so there are some
macroeconomic trends related to this
including the availability of other
kinds of capital but some of this and
what he talks about in his book and what
my research speaks to is the way that
technology is underlying some of these
trends so what we're going to talk about
today is how technologies are changing
the basic ways that people organize work
and organize businesses so the
historical trends that we're looking at
are what we should be thinking is about
thinking about is how work was organized
in the past and how technologies are
changing that so what I'm illustrating
here is some of the oldest
organizational charts in the United
States and what these are speaking to is
a way that public corporations grew up
really around railroads and around large
scale manufacturers so these kinds of
corporations required a huge workforce
of white-collar professionals who are
doing the professional administrative
and clerical work to coordinate these
large-scale operations so in the past we
had a large workforce doing the
coordination and decision-making and now
increasingly what we see is that
software and different kinds of
platforms are doing the kinds of work
that the white-collar administrative
clerical administrative professionals
we're doing in the past so the main
argument of this book is that the
technologies that organize coordination
and decision making have changed so
there
of different ways that this conversation
is be had a lot of different ways that
people are making this point so I'll
just call out a few before we get into
the specifics of flash teams and flash
organizations which is what my research
is about so in this paper that I'm
illustrating here which I highly
recommend Jerry Davis talks about the
different kinds of robust organizational
alternatives that are enabled by new
technologies so for example pure
production so something like Wikipedia
so when you have a template and the
internet then anyone online can come and
edit a page in the encyclopedia and then
you have this large crowd that
participates in the creation of
something new so that's different than a
way that a hierarchical organization is
organized and run so having those kinds
of peer production or open innovation
platforms is an example of one of the
reasons that corporations or
organizations are disappearing and
shrinking others have talked about this
in different ways so for example I was
presenting something like this and a
venture capitalist named Roy the Hutt
tweeted me an article about how now
software is the new organizational chart
so the example there would be something
like holla cracy or systems of record so
when you have software this sort of
underlies all of the decisions in
coordination it really changes the way
work is done so that's kind of the
historical trend that we're seeing this
is relevant because most of society is
organized around these large scale
organizations and as they're changing
and the structures of society are
changing too so I'm going to use this as
the motivating quote for the remainder
of the presentation so jerry davis
having studied the vanishing corporation
in the united states has this sort of
provocative way of thinking about this
he says that organizational design is
now a subfield of computer science so
i'm gonna give you some examples of why
he says that sort of what it means and
then how this idea of using tools and
tech for team design fit into this idea
so the first example of organizational
design now being a subfield of computer
science is the web-based enterprise so
let's start with back at the example of
Circuit City so what was going on there
so the technology that underlies this
change is actually not very advanced or
revolutionary at this point as Gerry
points out it's something simple called
the application programming interface
and all that means is a way that the
front half of the website talks to the
back half of the website so you'll have
a customer inquiry on the website that
can now do a query to the database so
that was something that used to require
a white-collar professional who would
check you know check that customer
inquiry and then look in the database
and so that's now something that is
automated so his point is that with the
API doing a lot of the coordination work
we're going to see an increase in what
he calls the web page Enterprise so I'm
going to use his favorite example here
this is kind of a whimsical example I'm
it's a new kind of consumer cult product
called the instant pot so the point with
the instant pot is this was a new
product category on Amazon that now has
over for almost 40,000 five-star reviews
and what's interesting about this is the
instant pot started with a staff of five
people and an investment of 350,000
dollars so they were able to weave
together this ecosystem of online
Internet resources to create develop
produce manufacture ship sail uh sell
and market this new product so I'm going
to call out this New Yorker article from
2013 by Nathan Heller that sort of
explains what's going on here and why we
can expect to see an increase in the web
page enterprise
so Nathan Heller published this in 2013
after interviewing some people who are
working in the Silicon Valley kind of
San Francisco market and his informant
was explaining this I'm saying in 2005
the whole thing exploded did you need
hardware no now you just put it on
Amazon or Rackspace software now it's
all open source
distribution it's just the app store
it's Facebook customer service that's
just Twitter you just respond to your
best customers on Twitter and get
satisfaction sales and marketing now
it's Google words Adsense so the cost to
build and launch a product went from
five million to 1 million to 500,000 now
it's 50,000 so the the revolutionary
technology behind all of this is the API
it's a very simple technology but it
makes coordination and decision-making
much easier and automated and we're
seeing this used in a lot of different
organizational applications now so I was
giving you an example of the webpage
Enterprise and now let's get into team
design which is the motivation of this
webinar so in this whole arc of talking
about how technology changes
organizations what we're seeing now is
that you can use API is basically to
interface with a workforce so we see
that in crowdsourcing and we see that in
the flash team's research let me
illustrate a little bit about how that
works so several years ago a PhD student
daniela ruah tell me a computer science
professor Michael Bernstein and a group
of other PhD students master students
and I did research to develop a web
platform called foundry so the thing to
think about with foundry is it's a web
platform that allows team design so
anybody can come to foundry which is an
open source platform and can basically
author a flash team and then foundry
interfaces with online labor markets
where there are millions of people
millions of workers who are available
and registered in upwork who can come
work on the flash team so I want to talk
about some of the features of this
platform and the way that it connects to
this overall trend of using more
technology to do the coordination and
decision-making that people and
organizational charts were doing the
past
so an important component or feature of
foundry is that it interfaces with large
online labour markets when we did this
study several years ago we configured
foundry to interface with a labor market
called up work so upper calm so up work
has millions of people who are expert in
various kinds of professions like web
development mobile app development we
worked with people who are product
designers content creators editors we
had people who did marketing business
plans so basically the way that foundry
works is it will issue an open call to
the people on up work who have
registered to work on a flash team for
the first research project that we did
we were trying to demonstrate that this
kind of approach could be as fast as
previous crowd sourcing approaches so we
configured foundry to hire first-come
first-serve which will obviously
optimize on speed and the efficiency of
hiring and then I'll talk later about
different ways to configure the
composing or assembling of a flashing so
basically foundry interfaces using this
sort of like API approach to a large
online labor market and then that people
will click on the link and then be
brought to foundry and then they'll see
what their role is in the overall flash
team they'll see the workflow they'll
see what their first task is they'll see
the way that their task is
interdependent with other people on the
team they can upload deliverables which
will automatically pass them along to
other people on the team and then there
are different features for the
management of the flash team which will
show like what work is on time what work
is at risk and the different ways that
people can talk to each other the other
feature of foundry that is interesting
for managers who are thinking about team
design is that we configured it so that
it could be basically like an
organizational chart that anybody who is
working on the flash team
edit so what I'm picturing here on the
bottom left so think of that as a
website a web portal that anyone on the
team has access to so you see sort of
the participants of the team down the
left side and then the different tasks
that they're a part of kind of next to
them so the way that this works is
anyone can make a copy of the
organizational chart or the workflow and
then they can make a suggestion
so they'll basically add a task or add a
role in their copy and then when they
merge it back in then everyone else will
see what their suggestion is so what's a
cool property about this is it allows
for top-down or bottom-up
recommendations to how to change the
team design or how to change the
organizational chart so if somebody on
the front line sees that their team is
maybe meeting another person or if they
see that the hierarchy isn't working the
way that it's configured and they can
make a suggestion on the org chart and
when they merge it back in then somebody
will review it they'll review what the
suggestion is and they can accept the
suggestion change a reject it and then
the suggestion will appear on everybody
else's page for how the work is going to
be structured going forward so again
there's lots of different ways that you
could configure this you can imagine
what would happen if you made this sort
of like a democratic boat like let's say
that somebody makes the suggestion that
the hierarchy should be switched up for
some portion of the task and then
everyone on the team could sort of vote
if that's what should happen so you can
have this like democratic review of the
suggestion the way that we had it
configured during the study was to have
the managers were the ones who always
approved the different suggestions that
were edited in so again it's interesting
to think about this as the platform is
now something that is dynamically
editable by anyone on the team and that
sort of changes the properties of
organizational structures organizational
design and also the way that those
decisions get made
so we ran a proof-of-concept study to
show that this kind of approach could be
used to crowdsource really complex
projects so what I'm illustrating here
are the different organizational
structures that emerged in the three
different studies that we ran so each of
these started with just the sort of
person who's our client the person who
had the idea so illustrated in the top
is sort of this black figurehead so it
started like that and then over time
they would add a different role a
different team a different hierarchy and
these are the organizational structures
that emerged
and I'll show here the workflows that
emerged so each of these tasks was added
over time the colors of the task boxes
illustrate the different teams so for
example in the top you're looking at one
of the one of the projects that we ran
and you can see that towards the end of
it that's when the QA which is in orange
the Quality Assurance team came online
and started doing all of their tasks so
the other thing that's interesting to
think about here with flash teams and
with this kind of archival record of all
the work that was done is the kind of
data science that can be done on the
tasks the roles the interactions the
hierarchy so this starts to enable a lot
more data science or sort of empirical
analysis of team design of how the work
is structured um of how sort of the work
unfolds over time so I Ellis traited the
webpage enterprise and then flash teams
so the webpage enterprise you're using
API to sort of connect different
components of a website with flash teams
you're connecting a client or somebody
who has ideas with a whole team of
people using an online neighbor market
and a flash team using a flash team
platform like foundry what I want to
talk about now is some of the later
research that we did after we ran the
flash team's experiments and where we're
continuing to see what was possible when
you use kind of software when you use
platforms to do some of this kind of
organizing work so the next example I
want to talk about is different ways
that you can use software to to sort of
think through the flash team members
who's going to be on the team
so the first example that I showed we
were optimizing on kind of speed and
efficiency because we were in
conversation with the crowd sourcing
research community I want to talk now
about another model that was developed
neela far Silla he who is now a
professor at UC Berkeley in this yes
Department so she was the PhD student
who led this research and basically her
idea was to notice that the work of
flash teams and flash organizations was
basically sacrificing some of the
familiarity of team members in order to
get speed so if you're just doing a
first-come first-serve to a large labor
market that means you're just gonna get
who's available you're going to get fast
staffing of the team but what she was
wondering is was there a way that you
could staff the team to really focus on
the relationships between the team
members in general this kind of model
could be configured in several different
ways you could maybe be optimizing for
different kinds of expertise you could
be optimizing for different time zones
different availability different
experience levels so the variables that
we're optimizing here are the speed that
we demonstrated with flash teams in the
past and then with familiarity with
people working together and sort of
accumulating a lot of experience working
together over time so basically what she
wanted to do with this study was to
develop a system an algorithmic system
that would assemble or staff the flash
teams in a way that optimized the
relationships of the past so team
members who had worked together before
were weighted more heavily when staffing
the next flash team that was being
developed so she developed another
platform called Hudler and Hudler would
keep track of all of the times that
people had worked together in the past
and then use that information to staff
the teams going forward so we ran a
study this is published and available on
her website so ran a study that
basically showed that using the Hudler
algorithm that optimized for both
familiarity and availability we were
able to quickly staff flash teams where
team members had worked together in the
past which is one of the predictors of
really effective teams
all right I want to now give my final
example of how organizational design is
now a subfield of computer science so
this is a continuation of the flash
team's research stream
so if you think about this kind of
overall idea you have a platform that
interfaces with labor markets or even
large internal populations of employees
and then convenes teams to work together
on a project so there's different
features that we're talking about here
one is the assembly feature which is
figuring out who should be on the team
and sort of assembling them together the
second piece is how the platform can
help people work together more
effectively so this last example that
I'm giving is most led by a PhD student
named Sharon Zhu and she was looking at
how the platform could interact with
team members to help them work together
more effectively so this is the paper
that she led she talked about it as
searching for the dream team so I like
this visual because what this is showing
basically is the idea of how the
platform helps the team members work
together effectively so basically what
you're seeing here is three different
teams you have ABC and then on the Left
you have different kinds of team
structures that the teams could use to
coordinate their work so you could have
a centralized hierarchy or a
decentralized hierarchy you could have
different ways that the team members are
interacting with each other they could
add like an emergent kind of interaction
pattern they could have some sort of
like round-robin or equally distributed
interaction pattern so what you see
illustrated here is of the ten rounds
that the team's work together they
adopted different team structures based
on the algorithms that I will talk about
in just a minute that was recommending
what structures they should be using
so what's interesting about this
research I think in particular is it is
a really nice illustration of the kind
of technical innovation that's needed
for this kind of work and then the kind
of basic social science or like
managerial intuition that's needed for
this kind of work so what Sharon was
sort of speaking to when she was leading
this project is a sort of known body of
research in organizational design or
management about how to structure teams
and what all of this research has shown
is that there's basically not a
universally ideal way to structure a
team it's gonna depend on who the team
members are what kind of tasks they're
working on is it like an execution pads
for an innovation task so knowing this
and sort of being familiar with this
research she developed this algorithmic
approach that was going to explore all
of the different spaces that teams could
use to structure and then recommend
different ones to the team leaders or to
the managers she ran an experiment that
showed that the teams that were sort of
running with this dream team system
outperformed the manager led teams or
the self-managed teams by about 40% in
this one experiment so the different
structures that could be recommended to
the teams are sort of listed here so
there are a bunch of different ones that
they could look at I talked about
hierarchy and interaction patterns I'll
notice at the bottom there's one
feedback norms so people could give
could be encouraged to recommend it to
give really encouraging feedback a
really critical feedback so this is sort
of the space of all the different
structures that the teams could use to
facilitate or coordinate their work this
is sort of the decision space that the
managers and team members were exploring
to figure out how they should be working
together how they should structure their
work so the way that this worked is she
configured basically a slack bot and the
slack bot would so the team members
would come into slack and they would be
interacting with each other and they
would
to play a game for one round at the end
of the round the slack bot would collect
feedback from all of the team members
about how things have been going and
then using that data the slack bot would
then recommend that they stay with the
same structure that they had before or
try and experiment with a new structure
so you can see an example here this is
one of the actual teams that was running
so you can see that team member is kind
of joking around and is saying I'm too
scared to type anything and then the
slack bot recommends that they adopt a
very cheerful encouraging way of giving
feedback to each other and then after
that the team members again this is kind
of joking an interaction with the bots
the team members say they're saying like
go team we're killing it so there's kind
of like feedback evaluation
recommendation feedback loop is the kind
of thing that we're thinking about here
and what the algorithm was doing to sort
of run the bot behind the scenes was
figure out if the bot should recommend
staying with the same structure or
trying a new structure and what Sharon
found in a study is basically when so
the dream team teams outperformed the
other teams so when she dug into the
system of the dynamics of what was
happening there she saw that the
managers when the managers are running
the team they weren't trying enough
variations they sort of found a
structure that worked and just stayed
there stayed with that structure so the
dream teams outperformed the manager led
to use because they explored more they
explored more structures and then this
self-managed teams are the teams that
kept getting recommendations about how
to change adopted they changed too often
which gave the the team members started
to ignore the recommendations because it
was too many recommendations and too
many changes so the dream team algorithm
had this way of sort of figuring out how
much to explore versus how much to sort
of stay with the same structure that had
been working in the past so in general
the
team bot interface is just this proof of
concept of the idea that now that teams
are increasingly working on platforms
and everyone's sort of interacting in
this platform the platform can be
configured to have these kinds of like
latent measurements of feedback or how
things are going sort of a latent
collection of data analysis of data and
then some sort of recommendation to try
to help the teams perform better now
obviously across all of this there's
going to be um it's going to be really
important that whatever platform
whatever algorithm is being designed is
done in collaboration with the people
who it's acting upon otherwise there
will be a lot of kind of gaming or not
using this system so it has to be
something that is working for the people
that it's trying to help instead of some
sort of like top-down tech design which
tends to get ignored suburban or game so
those are the examples of how team
design is now happening increasingly on
platforms using data for assembling
teams for helping them coordinate and
how this sort of allows for different
properties of the teams they're
happening you know increasingly outside
of organisations or in these sort of
optimized ways within organizations so I
wanted to conclude on this slide which
is sort of what do you take away from
all of these kinds of studies and this
the kind of future of work conversation
and across the number of different
studies that we've done or the different
kinds of conversations that we've been
having with different leaders of
organizations here's sort of the
takeaways this is kind of where I see
things this is where I see the
conversations sort of happening getting
a little bit stuck in organizations this
is opportunities basically so the first
is all of this data can be used for
making decisions in
smarter more optimized ways data can be
helpful what I see is sort of the limit
in a lot of organizations right now is
actually access to data or to data
infrastructure so a lot of the managers
that I talk to will have will sort of be
bought into this vision of how software
and how data can be used for organizing
and for coordination but basically it's
hard to get it done in their company or
in their organization just because the
data infrastructure is not there like
people don't have access to data they
don't have yeah that the tools with
access to the data and non siloed ways
to sort of do this kind of optimized
decision-making so investing in access
to data and sort of like a really broad
open data infrastructure seems to be a
capability that a lot of people are
working on right now and then part of
that is now that managers and different
occupations are using data to do things
like team design team assembly to
support team coordination or just other
kinds of decision-making like market
research or things like that I'm seeing
a lot of conversation about companies
and occupations needing to develop a new
kind of data fluency so people who were
not necessarily having to use data for
the kinds of decisions they were making
in the past or now needing like data
curriculum what is what is like an a/b
test what is you know data science 101
the second takeaway I think for managers
that I'm seeing as a result of all of
these technological changes is that
people are needing new processes for
thinking about how to manage the
boundary of the firm what I mean by that
is like up work is this large online
labor market of really expert people and
then there are companies that are
interfacing with online labor markets
are sort of like I mean it's it's a it's
another way of thinking about
outsourcing so I'm seeing a lot of
conversation around how organizations
can interface with the crowd can
interface with online labor markets can
interface with freelancers or people who
are
working outside of the organization
there are some really important social
implications and policy implications
that are part of a larger conversation
for the purposes of this webinar what
I'm seeing is that people are talking a
lot about how to manage the boundary of
the firm and how to sort of coordinate
with the crowd the last piece of it is a
lot of this is new a lot of it is
emergent a lot of it is changing there's
a lot of cool opportunities so there's
not really a vow held or like a right
way to do this at this point what I'm
seeing be the most successful is
companies that are investing in kind of
human centered design around this and
looking for really kind of tight
feedback loops in trying something doing
some sort of like Co design with workers
with the employees and figuring out how
to configure these things in a way that
supports work and that supports
workflows and helps people kind of do
the kind of work in the way that they
want to and really what we're kind of
virtuous feedback loop so these are the
kinds of problems that I'm seeing in a
lot of the examples of how of the
conversations of how to sort of start to
think about using software for
organizational design and team design
and organizations and I look forward to
continuing conversation all right thank
you so much Melissa for this very
informative presentation it's such a
timely and important topic I think it'll
really help everyone the first one is
your paper on flash teams stated that
this method can be used for engineering
and design work but is there a
limitation on the type of work that
these kinds of methods can be used on
and do you plan any future research on
different types of work yeah thank you
for that question that reminds me of
something that I had wanted to mention
actually we're so we're seeing a lot of
different examples of now industry use
cases of something like flash teams so
for example there's a some cisco startup
called gigster that does software and
engineering so that's similar it's
what we were talking about but there's
actually a lot of other models that I'm
seeing some cool examples include there
something called art Ella Art Ella is
artists so they're digital artists do
they sort of have like the way that the
way that the founder explained it to you
is they have like the Pixar workflow but
then they have like a community of
people who do digital animation who can
come participate in the different
projects that each other pitch there are
something called Catalan which does this
kind of model for business plans so it's
basically a network of like MBAs so if
you need to do a flash business plan you
can interface with MBAs you do this so
I've seen I've seen it and I've given
this presentation I've heard people have
ideas for like flash teams of
accountants for like audits so I think
for project for project based work we're
gonna see an increase in this kind of
idea of like platform mediated projects
so I think it works well for project
work I think the open question and this
is something that we've thought a lot
about as well the open question is what
does the sort of maintenance of whatever
the deliverable was so if you have this
like body of code if you have like the
sort of like you know that code that of
the mobile app like who maintains that
over time when you have this kind of
flash model so the idea of the like core
the core team that stays on and
maintains versus like the peripheral
team that in a flash comes and helps
participate in building something up so
that the I think that ends up being the
where we're thinking about where
innovation would have to happen or like
new think you would have to happen is in
just like the maintenance of longer
projects because this works best for the
kinds of like short flash projects that
I've been talking about Thanks so here's
a more general question so teams have
always been used to get work done so why
are we better at it and why does
technology make a difference yeah that's
so that's a great question and I think
that's an important one and it's what
I'm thinking about what that question is
when I assign team projects in my
classes then it's it's - groans
Smet - groans nobody likes working at a
team because you end up with all the
social problems of you know maybe some
people are working harder than other
people you know maybe you have some like
funky hierarchy where the person who's
most expert is not the one who's in
who's it who has the authority so all of
the like social psychological problems
and challenges of groups remain
technology does not solve that Oh
sometimes technology can make it worse
we've seen like virtual teams and online
teams that research has shown tend to
have more conflict than others um so I
will say you know sometimes there
sometimes teams can be better than
working alone when you have like a
synergistic team where you're like
bouncing ideas off each other and you're
really like working together in this
innovative way that's the dream and I
don't think the technology in any
deterministic way it gets you from like
the bad team to the good team so that
the point is the point is is good but
the point stands teams are hard so has
your research found any way to control
for the quality of the final deliverable
um so so thank you again that's a really
good question
so our when we did the flash teams field
experiment one of the challenges that
the clients so they were the ones who
had the idea of what they would build
using the flash team so they were very
concerned about the quality of the
product that was being built and what
the feedback that we got from them is
that that is definitely a place where
the interface between an existing
organization where you oftentimes have a
lot of kind of like quality checks and
quality assurance built in place that's
where that interface can be kind of
problematic our place to really watch
for so again it's a really important
question and I think it's the right kind
of thing to be thinking about in our
study this the solve for it was was
simply around hierarchy it was simply
around having liked managers being the
ones who were accountable
whatever was turned in and for kind of
checking it so I have seen kind of
studies or I have seen different proofs
of concept where people are looking at
like technical solutions we're trying to
look at how to you know assess quality
and more like automated ways or whatever
so in our instance we just use type we
just use managers so the managers were
accountable for the quality of the
product we had Quality Assurance teams
so that's that's the the kind of like
old-school way managers armed with
technology sort of what's the what's the
fix and I think we'll see more kind of
studies of this in the future because it
is one of the main problems with
crowdsourcing great so you said
something about accountability and
sending it up and it reminded me of this
question that was asked so essentially
they're asking if leadership or managers
and ultimately make the decision to use
a digital team should they also design
the process wouldn't the project teams
do a better job how do you integrate
knowledge and decisions mmm yeah good
question
so the manager should not design the
team I agree with you I think I think we
are in in radical agreement here so I
think one thing so we had a flash team
study severally maybe five years ago and
then the one I was presenting is a
little newer so the the one we have done
initially we used a workflow where
everything was designed up front so that
would be something more like a manager
making all of the decisions for like how
things should be structured for very
very simple execution it was kind of
fine but what we saw is that like you
know like one task into those flash
teams the workflow was obsolete
this sort of like top-down design of how
things should go was already like
out-of-date obsolete and then the people
who are actually doing that work had to
improvise and they went very much like
off platform and just improvised a
better way to do it that fit their style
that fit their expertise that fit the
deliverable
better so that's actually what led us to
work on the new functionality and
foundry that allows for this kind of
editing over time so now a manager like
the client who has the idea basically
just starts with like a blank slate and
then hires people and then they
themselves edit ad team's add tasks kind
of decide what should happen over time
so it is much more emergent and much
more kind of team member designed
together over time
there are there were some challenges
with that like we got feedback from them
from the team members that sometimes
they wanted more direction from the
client manager and sometimes they wanted
less so it still is a little bit of a
balance but the functionality that I
would sort of look at there is the idea
kind of like code designing the workflow
co-creating the structures together over
time with some sort of dynamic interface
so we have I was just reviewing so we
have several questions on concerns about
IP and data so how do you how do you
address those kinds of concerns when
working on a flash team or or using a
flash game for work yeah so that's a
great question so intellectual property
is another really kind of key issue
around this flash team model when we did
the study we just followed the up work
policy for intellectual property so up
work has protections in place there's a
protections there policies in place that
basically says that the client owns the
IP and there's some there are some ways
that they through their sort of user
agreements deal with the IP issues of
having freelancers work on intellectual
property of a company or a client so
it's a it's a little bit of a punting
the question and just saying that the up
work labor market had their protections
in place and that's what we were relying
on when we did the flash teams I think
as organizations become increasingly
disintermediated we see more of these
kind of platform models and I suspect
there will be changes to policy I'm not
expert or not but maybe changes to the
way that IP is protected so this is it's
the right conversation and I think the
future might look different than what we
have now okay so I'm going to give you
two more two more questions that are
very common themes through here so the
first one is how how should people go
about trying to get this kind of work
started within a more mature
organization how do they get people to
be receptive to this not feel replaced
still feel like their work is important
while also having these these flash
games
hmm so there's there's sort of two
different concerns in that question I
think both are really valid one is sort
of had like how to have conversations in
large organizations that have an
existing way of doing things and one is
concerns about worker replacement and
kind of like worker rights and I think
both of those are really really
important
so I'm actually start with the first one
under the second one first I think that
there is a really broad conversation
going on right now about how kind of
like this social fabric of our society
and not to be dramatic but kind of like
this social fabric of our society so for
years and years the social safety net
has existed around organizations people
have had their entire careers and organ
like a single organization you know
health insurance retirement pension
career ladders like post-industrial
revolution society just evolved around
organisations and as that changes then
that means that there's a lot of a lot
more precarity and I a lot more from
caring for workers and again that's the
right conversation that should be like
the foreground of what we're talking
about with any of these like platform
models for organizing so it's just such
a larger conversation thank you for
bringing it up and I'll I'll know that
there just there are so many places of
that conversations happening and I hope
we all continue to participate in that
in terms
inside organizations how to start this
conversation what I've seen is that
there are people who will hear something
like this and they'll they'll sort of
recognize that there's like some sort of
data source in their organization that
could be used for this kind of
organizing and and then like a small
pilot like it just a small
proof-of-concept that shows how to use
those data to assemble a team or like a
small pilot that shows how I don't like
this
I mean slack doesn't solve everything
I'm not this is not me being tech
deterministic but just I guess what I'm
saying is like small pilots to
demonstrate proof of concept can start a
really interesting conversation I'm also
if you're interested in doing research
you can always contact academics see if
you can do a study together because
immense that will be a low-risk kind of
outside of the work flow but the
operational work flow way that kind of
explore these kinds of ideas another
idea okay last last one so how do how
does ideation innovation and execution
integrate to assign value for different
contributions so would you pay you know
if you had a base rate but then certain
people within the flash team and we're
performing at a much higher rate or
perhaps we're not performing that well
would you then adjust the compensation I
missed so it's an interesting question
to think about kind of how people are
how people's contributions are
recognized in different ways I'll tell
you the things that I've heard that I'm
not satisfied by but I think I know and
then I'll say what I think
so there's well I shouldn't say like
that so in terms of like because what I
would want to avoid what this
conversation is basically anything that
is like again like - like tech
deterministic like people are always
interesting in how they will enact these
different social systems so what I've
heard people talk about is like it's
different kinds of like micro equity or
sort of like some sort of like you know
how do you do like equity in a flash
team so that's an interesting idea
right if somebody if the client has this
idea and then people are contributing to
the idea in different ways is there a
way to sort of like measure and use data
to do equity and sort of like like
reimburse people or reward people who
are different they get rewarded people
for different ideas so yeah maybe maybe
that would be cool
um I think you know oftentimes this is
playing out just like in a market system
and capital will have capital and labor
is recompense for labor so it's part of
I think the overall Eakins ecosystem
will develop in a way that that sort of
changes that conversation in different
ways but I have heard I have heard like
different like tech ideas about it so I
would just encourage you to like Google
like equity for flash teams or something
like that if that's of interest but it
plays out in the larger ecosystem of
startups and like larger organizations
and things like that thank you
so people have been chiming in that this
was a really wonderful webinar so I just
wanted to thank you for for taking the
time and just for everyone who's online
I wanted to let you know that melissa
has a course coming out in November on
this very topic so we will provide
information with that with the follow up
email that you that you will be
receiving which will also include a
recording of today's webinar we want to
thank you so much for your time today
and have
great week